when i went back dave during this yeah
it was nuts what the hell happened to
these people what happened to them what
happened to the show
what's going on here i mean i got i went
through a full pre-interview they knew
exactly where i stood on the mandates i
was naive i was naive i felt like well
they know where i stand i'm gonna go on
they're gonna have a real conversation
with me i don't know why i thought that
but i thought well it would be
ridiculous i was a former co-host it
would just be so disrespectful to to do
anything but have a real conversation
i'm dave rubin and joining me today is a
former co-host on the view former fox
news anchor and author of two
best-selling books and now host of the
jedi avila live podcast on valuetainment
tv jenna diabela welcome to the reuben
report thank you for having me dave
always a pleasure to be here always a
pleasure in this florida heat
nonetheless
in this florida heat so that is a good
place to start us off first time first
off many of my viewers will know you
already from a million things that
you've done and you've been on the show
on the panel before we've never had you
for a proper sit down that's why i
wanted to do this and i should note for
those playing along at home that this is
airing in august i am off the grid i
have no phone no tv no news no nothing
but we did want to pre-tape some stuff
for you good people and jedi i thought
you would be a good one for this because
you are like me you are a new floridian
and i sense
that you are living your best life since
fleeing new york
i am i'm loving the vitamin d i will
tell you that the sunshine and the
freedom that's why i came here you know
i have a two and a half year old and
it's been really amazing you know i
lived in new york my whole life so
there's always that hesitance to move
right and i was one of those people that
was like no i'm gonna change new york
from the inside i'm gonna stay i'm gonna
it's it's almost impossible to do that
you know it really is hard when people
continue to vote like robots in those
places and it's just like oh who's on
the ticket there's a d it could be a
total [ __ ] i'm just gonna vote for them
anyway and wreck the city so i picked up
i came out to florida and i have to say
it's just the feeling it's just more
calming i feel like
now my views of like you own your own
life you're a free individual you're a
free citizen now align with the place
that i live plus how exciting is it
going to be to actually vote in a place
where it's exciting to vote because it's
like you never know how it's going to
you know we're always watching florida
right we're always like new york and
california yeah that's decided in like
20 seconds after the polls close but
florida's always kind of like what's
gonna happen so i think it's really
exciting it's an exciting time to be
here i think ron desantis um is doing a
fantastic job showing a lot of
leadership uh while a lot of other
republican governors are asleep and it
just it feels good it's just it feels
good to be here right now
well i don't want to disappoint you i
know this isn't going to really
disappoint you but don't worry we're a
red state this place is staying red
desantis is going to crush it in
november it's gonna go red no matter
who's running for president so i know
that's not as exciting as being in a
swing state but uh nonetheless i know
for a fact i got here on december 17
2021 what what day did you get here do
you know the day because for me it's
etched in my brain in stone uh i don't
remember we've been here for about four
months now but i don't you were a little
behind me you were about two months
behind me or something i was i was and
we changed our date a number of times
and then it was really funny when we got
down here the place that we had planned
to live in was not as advertised so we
lived at hotels for a while so that's
probably why it's a little mixed up in
my head but what i do remember is a
conversation i had with my mom
when i got here and that was the one
challenge i'm a family girl so leaving
my family in new york
they're not quite ready to move yet
although now my mom just came down here
and she's like i gotta get down here
the one thing i remember feeling is just
i took a deep breath i was sitting on
the beach and i was like
wow i just feel like i shed a whole
bunch of baggage that i had on my back
in new york city there were so many
restrictions and at the time it was in
the heat of the mandates and you know
you're not my friend you're my enemy you
didn't get the vaccine and it was like
all of that just turmoil the crime and
it just felt so i felt light i don't
know how else to say it i felt like
light and airy and like i was ready to
like re-embrace life and i think i did
your show
soon after that on the panel or and you
were no you you you just sound different
and i was like well did you did that was
like two weeks after yeah yeah you were
like jumping out of your skin basically
and i was like oh i know the feeling i
actually still have that feeling yeah
yeah no 100 and i think you know for
people like us you know you you're
coming from california i'm coming from
new york i think for people who really
believe in freedom i don't think we
realized at least let me speak for
myself there was a lot of frustration
that was in me and especially when i had
a child and i realized wow this system
is so broken and then i saw the crime
and i was like what what can i do and
there was just so much frustration
brewing that finally to be in a place
where freedom is prioritized where these
values that we hold so dear
are
front and center where you know you're
going to raise your kid in a place you
know and i don't know listen i don't
know if i'm going to be in florida
forever but i will tell you this dave
i'm never going back to a blue state i'm
done you know if i go anywhere it's
going to be maybe i go to texas maybe i
you know dip a foot in tennessee or you
know have you know florida and it's i'm
not going back to that though there's a
darkness and there's a dystopian just
you know those dystopian movies that we
used to watch and say well that's not
real life thank god yeah that's what it
feels like tangibly in a lot of these
woke cities around the country and
states and i'm just i'm not going back
so
for the record i am never leaving
florida they will take me out two feet
first if they take me but i will be
buried in florida i am never leaving
florida i will be swimming with the
gators
as they say dave you're committed i i
don't know what was that thing you had
on the wall at one point it was like
some florida i don't know if it was was
it lizards or the little oh what
well it was all meant to be for me
because i've i've actually always loved
florida my whole life and my my folks
have lived down here for part of the
year so i've always been coming down so
those what you're talking about i had
two oh you might be talking about one of
two things i have two giant alligator
uh
canvases uh these like six foot canvases
that i've had for years but i think what
you're talking about is that we have a
whole wall of alligator skin wallpaper
and one day i woke up in the morning and
there was a lizard on the alligator skin
wallpaper and i was like this is as good
as it gets listen it's commitment it's
commitment from you i love it and coming
from california you know the thing is
like a lot of people go to california i
say now
only the only sane people that would go
to california is just people who love
the weather if it's not the weather i
really don't know what you're doing
there you're not going to grow a
business there the taxes the tax
structure is just not incentivizing it's
not welcoming to entrepreneurship i
don't i don't know why you would go to
california if it's not a weather
decision but for someone like you who
does i'm guessing you're not a fan of
the cold i'm just going to put that out
there i don't love the cold but but
correct me if i'm wrong the the summer
has been pretty fine here i know they
had they sang it's unseasonably it's not
raining as much as usual but it's been
fine it's fine i like sweating
there you go detox
exactly so i want to ask you something
because since we come you know i'm
originally a new yorker before my crazy
eight years in cali so since we come
from such a similar place and now i
think our political outlook and our sort
of life outlook are very similar what do
you think about the people the kind of
people that were the northeast people
let's say the new york people that
should have some fight in them the cali
people a lot of them just seem fried to
me or like northern cali okay wine
country socal san diego you're just sort
of fried by the weather and okay you
just accept it new yorkers have a
fighting spirit and and that's why it
was so hard for me to see and i still
have a ton of family in new york so many
people just accept it and not only
accept it but like thank you sir may i
have another and you know they're
bringing as i'm off the grid right now i
don't know if mass mandates are back in
cali they're supposed to be right now
and they could be back in new york and
people would welcome it
yeah new york is has lost its soul i've
said many times you know i grew up there
and there was a rebellious spirit in new
york it was really rebellious and it
used to be an enclave for like if you
went downtown manhattan was like artists
and writers and people who challenged
the status quo and of course yes the
city always was liberal but they would
challenge like corporate america and big
pharma i mean big pharma would have been
a huge target by those people they would
have not been like they would have not
liked to be told what to do they would
have been like oh i got 16 you know jabs
and i'm going to be online for the 17th
one and it's okay to tell people if they
don't get a vaccine they can't go into
the deli i mean that is not the new york
that i know and i think that was what
was the big challenge for me is that i
saw a hypnotized population just like
kind of like the walking dead i mean i
hate to say it but just like kind of
robotically walking around
when i say a dystopian nightmare i mean
a dystopian nightmare and it's just lost
its spirit it's lost its soul i think
that people have become allies of the
state you know and now it's just like a
bunch of people who believe politicians
over there they've lost that that fire
that energy and and the city doesn't
read the same that it used to it doesn't
read like a hub of cultural activity i'm
sorry but it doesn't it reads like a
crime infested
area where you're afraid to you know you
don't want to you don't want to build a
family there because you're not only
worried about the crime but you're
worried about the mandates you're
worried about what happens in cycle two
we all know there's gonna be a cycle two
of this pandemic it's come it's coming
it's gonna be the math maybe it'll come
just in time for the next election who
knows
you think i think but the next time it
rolls around now you know that you know
you can look around the country and know
where those populations live where
they're just gonna lie down and take it
oh you wanna shut down my business okay
oh you wanna you know mandate that i get
a vaccine or i can't a vaccine that
doesn't stop transmission or i can't go
into a restaurant okay like
where is their line in new york just in
terms of making decisions for themselves
and their families so i don't know what
caused it but now there's like a
subservience to authority it's like oh
you're in a position of authority you
must know better oh
i must be it's like everyone thinks
they're an idiot now oh i must just wait
i know i have common sense but i guess i
must be wrong and bill de blasio at the
time must be right it's it's disturbing
and it's a lack of autonomy and it's a
lack of self-sufficiency and a lack of
personal responsibility all those things
i hold dear they're just not there
anymore on top of that you got the crime
so you're like wow i used to love new
york because you know it was you could
go out on the town now it's like well if
i go one block over i might get knifed
so maybe i won't do that either so it's
just
it's a sinking city in many respects and
you know my friend buck sexton put a
tweet out a couple of weeks ago and he
was a few weeks ago and he was talking
about
you know you hear it sounds like a scene
from a bad movie going on outside you
know with just
it's crazy it's really really crazy um a
police force that doesn't feel supported
it's just so many factors and i i i love
new york so when i say it needs to sink
i say that from a place of love like you
need to sink or you're not you're that's
going to be your only motivation to wake
up maybe it'll wake up voters maybe it
won't i don't know i think the people
who flock to cities like that now are
perfectly comfortable
folding into a brave new world they're
comfortable with it well i'm so glad
that you said that that you want it to
come back because that i mean i spent
most of my adult years in new york city
my grandparents lived in new york city
although i grew up in long island so i
was always going to new york city i
remember as a kid i hated it because i
thought it was this dirty weird place
and then as then i was an adult and i
loved it i loved the grittiness and the
reality and the artists and all of the
stuff that was new york and it just
doesn't happen anymore you know
something you said before that about the
dystopian part it wasn't just the
lockdowns and the crime and all that
stuff but it was for me it was something
else in la that i when i would go to the
supermarket and by the end i really
stopped going out because i just hated
everybody and i was like i'm just not
going to go out anymore which also isn't
healthy but i remember that there was
like this blank look in everybody's face
like p you'd be walking around i'd try
to take my mask off and i'd be yelled at
everywhere i went but that there was
like no there was no fight with the
people and then you could almost see in
a weird way how when they talk about the
holocaust how a certain demonization of
people are certain you don't look at
other people as human and i kind of felt
that weird thing like no one was looking
at each other anymore we were just these
orbs bouncing around in the egg section
or the fruit section and then go about
our lives and that is not healthy for a
society yeah and people just bought into
this fear so extensively that they
became afraid of other people i mean i
remember watching a clip on the view
where that went through my timeline that
joy had said something like oh well you
know now that the masts are here i mean
why not always have them on like i mean
yeah replace i mean you could get the
flu first of all that's idiotic
from just from a scientific perspective
you know that if we're not exposed to
germs that's how we build an immune
system so it's idiotic on that level and
it's also like wow she that told me
something about her and it told me
something about a lot of people that
you know have her her ideology her
worldview they're really comfortable in
a world without that interaction like
this whole thing you're talking about
like glazed over eyes
follow authority do as i'm told you know
you're not my friend you're my enemy
because you didn't obey the rules there
there is a segment of the population
that is very comfortable with that they
want to be told what to do they're
uncomfortable making their own decisions
they're uncomfortable with other people
making their own decisions this whole
idea of freedom and liberty is
uncomfortable for them in many ways and
this was a manifestation of that so it
was like we all need to sit back and
realize that it's not just people that
are being tugged into this there are
people that are willingly walking into
this brave new world that they will say
yeah sure oh take my arm i don't oh i
don't need to ask questions about safety
or dad and no no no i trust you and then
there's a segment of the population
that's resistant to that that wants to
think for themselves that doesn't want
to be told what to do that that wants to
be able to ask tough questions and that
isn't comfortable with a government
authority or a bureaucrat or whoever it
may be or or a corporate bureaucrat for
that matter telling them what to do the
population the split in the population
has never been clearer to me and a lot
of those you know
zombie types i'm sorry live in these
woke cities and i don't think they're
going anywhere they wouldn't be
comfortable in florida because there's
so much risk dave there's too much risk
in the real world you know
for short though those freedom-loving
people you talk about the end those are
the racists right i'm just trying to be
clear on what you're saying racist
homophobe make it transphobic you name
it there's a label for
what choose one for the day
all right jedidiah you gave me a great
segue here because you mentioned joy
behar and the view and i talk often
about the view on this show we actually
show a warning before i play clips from
the view and it warns people that
whatever you're going to see is either
complete bs or insanity or something to
that effect i will say that many years
ago when i lived on the upper west i
lived two blocks away from joy behar i
would see her on the street she was not
insane back then i know it's hard for
people to believe but 10 years ago she
was not i loved her admired her she was
always very sweet to me her husband as
well
in my estimation she has lost her mind
whoopi has lost her mind
sonny i don't know what's going on there
i mean i i don't ever remember thinking
she was saying
anna these are crazy people that they
put at that table
jedediah you sat at that table for a
portion of your life and here you are
smiling in the free state of florida
explain that to people how does this
make sense yeah i mean and i didn't sit
there very long people may notice it was
about a year and a half i think i tested
for the show for a few months as i
recall i was still at fox i was actually
had one foot at fox as a contributor and
i was testing for that show at the same
time roger ailes at the time actually
gave me signed off on a like hey all
right she's probably not going to get
the job so let her just it'll be good or
go on over there and i was like i knew i
know i might be i was like great you
don't think i can get the job that only
helps me so i went over and i have to
say the show has changed drastically i
mean even in that show i mean that was
eight years ago it was a very different
show first of all it wasn't as hardwired
for politics at the time i was hosting
with like candace cameron and raven
simone so there was a lot more pop
culture
but there was also it still had that
barbara walters feel to it where she
really valued different viewpoints she
defended that i don't know if you
remember that show a lot a while ago i
mean it was before i got there for sure
where bill o'reilly was on and whoopi
walked off that was nice in many ways
that was the beginning of the end in
some respects when the two of them
walked off right but that wasn't
tolerated by her she made it clear that
this would be called the view because
there were supposed to be different
views at the table when i got to the
show i have to say
for the most part i had a good dynamic
with the ladies behind the scenes
there was some concern i remember a
couple of times with a couple of
episodes for example the day that
hillary clinton was coming on which
oddly wound up being a couple of days
before i lost my job i don't know but
regardless who knows but the day before
um the day she came on i remember there
was a lot of panic because i was very
big on the email scandal and they were
worried that i was going to bring up
something that was uncomfortable like i
had asked hey can i show this document
that she signed that said that she knew
exactly what the sea and confidential
meant and she lied to everybody she lied
and they were like oh i don't know
there was a lot of like walking through
the hallways quickly and what's judd's
gonna do that was well i actually didn't
get to an email question imagine that
i did ask her a question about being
tone deaf though so i felt like that was
gratifying for me but there was that
there was another instance i can't
recall i think maybe it was maxine
waters where i felt like tangible energy
of like uh oh you know
um the thing is though i noticed the
dress then i left the show i maintained
a good relationship with um you know the
the other hosts we had emailed here and
there
when i went back dave during the yeah
it was nuts what the hell happened to
these people what happened to them what
happened to the show
what's going on here i mean i got i went
through a full pre-interview they knew
exactly where i stood on the mandates i
was naive i was naive i felt like well
they know where i stand i'm gonna go on
they're gonna have a real conversation
with me i don't know why i thought that
but i thought well it would be
ridiculous i was a former co-host it
would just be so disrespectful to to do
anything but have a real conversation of
course i covet became an issue i
couldn't be on set even though i tested
covet negative in fact one time they i
was supposed to co-host several times i
was slotted to host i think four or five
times one time they came to my house
code tested me i tested negative i had
an exemption letter from my doctor that
said not only was i not a risk to people
at the time they were like she's not a
risk and here's her negative covet test
and this is medically advised against
for i submit all this stuff i test
negative and they say that's not good
enough you can't show up tomorrow i was
like and why'd you test me you're
testing the vaccinated people anyway it
made no sense
but anyway ultimately they tell me i
can't be in studio i do the show
remotely and everybody saw how that
unfolded which was a shout fest i was i
say two things and i get shouted down as
misinformation all i was saying was what
was had already been acknowledged by the
cdc which is that the facts can get and
spread covert so the mandate didn't make
any sense was very clear like everyone
should make their own personal decision
i didn't get an apology i didn't get
sonny went on some
tangent on on instagram of posting all
this stuff responding to me like instead
of responding to me in the show because
i didn't have an answer she went on
instagram it was i was like what is
going on you were at my wedding
girlfriend like what is going on here
so you know the commitment to the
ideology took precedence over
just mutual respect
over friendships over
it it's they've i'm sorry they've lost
their minds over there it's it's now a
panel of
a bunch of liberals and one person who
wears the label conservative but agrees
with them on all the things that they
deem must be agreed with right so it's
like oh you can't stray on the vaccine
so that person has to sit there now and
basically toe the line of the fake
conservative right they get to say they
have diversity on the panel they get to
say they have diversity of thought but
that person you know on these important
issues like a b and c
you can you either have to you know toe
the line we say or you have to make a
really feeble argument and let us win is
the bottom line
so i i just don't and you know megan
wasn't like that
i don't know megan mccain very well but
i worked her a little bit of fox but
she's feisty you know she wasn't any she
wasn't taking any garbage there you see
how that went you know it's hard it's
not what they want it seems to be that
now
you know that's just not what they're
looking for diversity of thought is just
not it's not what they're interested in
it's sad
um we could have had a great discussion
that day about mandates i think the
audience would have loved to hear but
they knew that if i was allowed to talk
there would be people that agreed with
me and they can't have that they can't
have it for people that have not seen
your appearance on the view that you're
referring to when they went off on you
on this way we did cover it on the show
so we'll link to that down below so
people can catch the the clips of that
because it's really incredible and the
dismissive way they treat you and as you
said sunny was at your wedding like like
really crazy stuff you know it's funny
because when i play clips of the view
and it's usually i'm i'm obviously i'm
making fun of them and it's in some ways
it's low-hanging fruit in a certain
degree but that thing for whatever
reason still is culturally relevant and
i think it's interesting that you
mentioned barbara walters because
obviously she was an icon of journalism
and she's not associated with it anymore
as far as i know or at least it's very
very behind the scenes um and obviously
she's she's older now but when she
started that thing that the very
purpose of the show was in the intro i
remember it 20 years ago we're going to
have these women of different walks of
life of different beliefs of different
religions of different skin goals that
we're talking about and now it's just
bash the hell out of whoever either a
fake conservative or a regular
conservative who can just take a beating
basically and megan couldn't take a
beating for that well she took it for
longer than you
and uh
yeah it's exhausting and also i mean the
whole you say that and that is true i
think for a long time the barbara
walters that's all true but you always
had to wonder like why why is it forward
against one then yeah right like that
doesn't even make sense like you should
have on there you know a bernie sanders
style democrat they should have a
moderate democrat they should have an
indep somebody who's maybe you know
completely independent they have uh uh
you know a moderate republican and then
a harsh like a strong you want to really
grab
you know you're talking about the view
it's like i don't need to see four
people pat each other on the back and
then one person get bullied that's not
enjoyable to me i think that it's it's a
household name it's a show that's been
around for a really long time i think
people say oh my my mom watched it you
know my my aunt watched it it was always
on in the house growing up it's iconic
but i have to say like it turned me off
i mean i was really
disgusted with how i was treated and i'm
also disgusted with the idea that like i
see i see who's going on there now and i
i see what's going on in the casting i
could just see it now i know they had a
problem with castings they everybody had
to be vaxxed and a lot of conservatives
were like i'm not playing that game yeah
i wasn't playing it obviously if i
couldn't go guest co-host a bunch of
times i wasn't going to be you know a
lot of people weren't playing that game
maybe that was a great way for them to
weed out the people they knew would be a
problem because it gets rid of you lisa
booth who's phenomenal good friend of
mine on fox news she refused to do the
guest gig because she or you know they
wanted her to get vacs to do it she said
no and then it's like okay that takes
out half the competition that
intellectually is going to own you
that's exactly right because those were
people who this was an issue where
people were saying you really had to
weed out people who were saying
i mean think about it though that's a
big show you know how many people would
have just got the vaccine just to do
that show oh no because it's an
opportunity it is an opportunity it's an
exposure opportunity it's all that there
were people who were willing to say i
prioritize my health i prioritize my
well-being and i prioritize my integrity
more than doing your show and that was
just the bottom line i did the same
thing she did i said i was lined up to
do i think three guest spots plus during
my book launch week a couple of spots uh
back to back we were going to do a whole
thing for my book and i was like you
know what
i i know my book i know this is going to
hurt my book i know the book has my
son's face on the cover but i want to be
able to tell my kid more important than
that i sat on the view to promote the
book i want to be able to tell my kid
one day that i didn't sacrifice my
principles or what was right for me or
my health or my family for some show
that couldn't accept a medical exemption
for a vaccine that doesn't prevent
transmission because they're too you
know doubled down on their their woke
ideology and their you know dystopian
nightmare to allow for some diversity of
thought that's something i'll be proud
to tell my kid one day
can you talk a little bit about like
just the tv production styles i don't
want to harp on the view the whole time
but i think it's important where now
like you know you in essence do a
version of what i do you're talking to
the camera you always have some
preparation when you do your show but
it's your thoughts and they're coming
out of you as you see fit and i'm sure
you work with some people behind the
scenes but but it is what it is right in
front of the camera where on television
whether it's the view or cnn or
everything else i think a lot of people
don't fully realize how scripted how
prepared how many voices are going into
their heads before the show we we posted
a clip a couple months ago of whoopi
talking about the vaccines and you know
my body get your hands off it and then
the complete reverse on abortion oh no
sorry i did it the other way where it
was vaccines it was you know everybody
get injected or you're going to be fired
and i'm not going to sit down with
jedidiah
and then abortion comes and it's nobody
touched my body like how the whole thing
is just
nonsense it's just nonsense yeah and
then and that makes no sense too and
their justification for that by the way
was always well that the vaccine affects
other people no it doesn't actually it
doesn't affect other people and they say
well abortion is only about you actually
no you have that wrong too because
abortion affects the person living
inside the woman's body i know i just
said woman and that's a controversial
word you said woman and person you're
really going for it that's going off all
over the place but yeah the production i
mean of these shows what people don't
understand one of the reasons why i'm
doing you know you your show was
actually a big inspiration for me i
don't know if you know that we've never
had that conversation but
i i really appreciate people who are
bringing unfiltered content that don't
have all of that going on behind the
scenes all those people in their ears
when you do a show like that i mean you
go to show meetings the topics are
chosen by producers you know based on
you'd sit in a room and where do you
disagree okay let's go with this topic
you know that's how it works there's a
lot of producer input on all you know
i'm not just talking about network on
cable news of what can be said of what
shouldn't be said of we're not going in
that direction you've got a question you
want to ask that's not the way they want
the segment to go you don't get to ask
it so there's a lot of frustration for
people who just want to have a real
conversation
the segments are timed very short as you
know you've done a lot of cable news
segments i'm sure you've done a lot of
segments everywhere so you don't really
get to the meat of the matter and
oftentimes on the view you'll notice
like whoopi gets the last word so you
could be in the heat of a debate and
she'll just you know it's wrapped but
she's going to get that last word in the
audience loves the audience is very
liberal so they'll clap and you're you
know you're it's a very difficult
position to be in um and truthfully i
think that over there they really they
don't want a likable conservative i
think that becomes a problem because of
the audience when i left that show one
thing people some people don't know is i
got a ton of messages from people that
were like on the left that were like you
know what i really respected you or i
really that was a problem for them
because those people's eyes and ears
were open and maybe they would be like
i was told conservatives were racist and
bigoted she sound that way you know so
but yeah there's a lot that goes into
the production there's meetings you know
producers pick the whole layout of the
topics there's stuff you can and can't
say there's you know people looking over
your shoulder if you stray you know it's
like oh she's a problem you know that
goes on across the board whereas now i
sit at my you know jetted ib alive i
pick my topics i say what i want to say
and everyone says to me now wow you
sound like you're it's like jet on the
loose and i'm like well it's different
you know it's it's in a sense you are
not cuffed in any respects you're kind
of just yourself which is something that
really appeals to me about what you do
what i do what a lot of people in the
podcasting space do right now
it's a it's a pretty sweet space to be
in right like this this new frontier i
mean it's funny because now i'm like an
old veteran of this because people
always say oh dave i watch your show now
i do something like this and i'm like
man how did i become the vet in this
situation but it's great because it's
like man we're still growing as that
thing deserves to fail
are you worried that as all of those
institutions fail and as cnn and the
rest of them fail that you know people
like us will be the only people turn to
and i think there is some risk in that
probably like we can do the best we can
but
can we solve all of it listen i think
it's for the better and i absolutely do
because i think that people who are
drawn to this space are free thinkers i
think we're independent free thinkers
and there's a fearlessness to it that
has to accompany this because you're
listen you're out there every day you're
saying how you feel you're going to be
held accountable you're not going to be
able to fall back on the cushion of a
network or oh you know i've got somebody
in my ear telling me to do this or do i
don't even have an earpiece on the show
i don't have anyone talking to me so if
i go rogue i have one only so i can hear
you nobody else can talk into this thing
i promise you
i'm always like guys if i burn the house
down i apologize in advance you know to
the to the tech people that are in the
room but a lot of the individuals
sitting in those network spots are very
uncomfortable with their own independent
thinking like they don't trust
themselves they so programmed and a lot
of these people are on the left in media
they've been so programmed again like
this this bow down to authority like to
authoritarians bow down to authority bow
down to politicians bow down oh what do
i need to say how do i need to wear this
i mean i've seen people on network tv
sit and figure out their talking points
of what they're going to say in a
20-second sound bike with a producer and
write it out and read it over and over
can you put that down and just tell me
what you think you know so i i would
rather have people joe rogan says all
the time on his show he'll be like i'm
not an expert like i don't know like i
don't he's willing to say i don't know
but people respect that because you're a
free thinking person you don't have like
loyalty to this or that or you're just
telling people what you think that's the
way to come to real solutions not
sitting behind you know a cushy network
job where you can say this and say that
you're completely filtered at all times
because there's always a worry about
this or that that's not getting that's
not getting anybody to any solutions so
i think it's a good move
were you uh ever worried on your little
red pill adventure in terms of like oh
man i'm really in this deep i think a
lot of people have that they start
getting red pilled about stuff they
start you know maybe during covey they
were questioning vaccines or lockdowns
then they start thinking about freedom a
little bit differently my god they maybe
read a thomas soul book or watch the
prageru video or saw one of us move to
florida and they start coming around but
then they freak out like oh my god
everything i knew was a lie am i really
surrounded by this many crazy people
could andrew cuomo and gavin newsom
really be devil worshipers is it all
true and it is um did you ever have any
moments along the way where suddenly you
were now more friendly with people on
the right you were getting probably tons
of hate from people on the left where
you were like wow this is this is
actually a little scary
no i'm going to tell you why because i
grew up as a conservative i was always i
always felt conservative and i grew up
in new york city and i went to columbia
university and i taught in academia in a
very liberal school so i was always very
used to like wow the crazies going on
around me i'm not it i wasn't i wasn't
drawn to it and i was always kind of
like like i always felt kind of like
alone on an island sometimes you know so
i i don't i truly if i'm being honest
found it very liberating once i
uh and listen i've made the right mad
too you know you and i both know that
they're yeah oh yeah i am a free thinker
like you know and i and i talk about
this sometimes um you know that
sometimes the right with the the the
fans of president trump the big maga
fans were always like oh are you
anti-trump or your aunt and i wasn't at
all but i was being honest with the
audience you know i was saying like hey
i don't know if i'm seeing a stolen
election like i'm talking to the jew
help me help me what am i missing like
that's who i am as a person i'm someone
who's gonna say
i am seeing i am seeing a desire to
steal an election as in collusion from
social media from big tech from big
pharma from the fouchy i saw what was
going on there that they tried to rob
him at that moment i wasn't seeing it
when it came to voting machines and
tallies so i was asking tough questions
i took heat for that you know and now
it's interesting a lot of people came
back and said to me you know something i
gave you a lot of heat for that a lot of
the audience came back and said i gave
you a lot of heat for that and i i
regret that because
now i appreciate that about you which i
love and i appreciate that somebody had
that reflective moment a lot of people
actually came to me and said that but to
be honest with you
when i when i left fox i think there was
a lot of people thought i was going to
leave fox news and i was gonna go work
at cnn
or i was gonna you know they were like
oh she's gonna go liberal and when they
saw that i actually sound more
conservative what the message that i
really wanted to get out there is all i
really wanted was to be completely
unleashed
i felt that need at this stage of life
to just kind of let it all out there and
i'm on my show talking about dating and
relationships a lot i'm talking about
you know why gentlemen have disappeared
i'm talking about things that i never
had the opportunity to talk about i'm
going to make people mad
on every side of the aisle you know but
i'm here to fix stuff and i'm here to
break stuff down and be real and this is
the moment for that you know this is the
moment in the podcasting world this this
is kind of our moment i feel like um so
i feel liberated if i'm being honest and
i never worry if i'm too conservative i
mean now it's kind of fun i can like i
mean kamala harris last week and i was
doing the cackle i didn't do a great
cackle i'm not gonna lie i did and i
said well it's great to be able to just
do that like you know you feel it and
you just let it out it's great
well you just realize it's like you can
say stuff and if you don't let them
control you they can't control you so
whether i'm doing
trying to explain rachel levine he she
whatever guy in a dress girl you know
leah thomas has a penis he she she
whatever is the number one women swimmer
and it's like if you if you fear that
they're gonna cancel you over it they
will but if you don't fear it
then it's then it's either funny to talk
about or at least you can get it out
sensibly 100
100 i think i feel the same way it's
just like you just you feel like you're
just able to just
you know i don't care people say to me
you're afraid to get canceled i'm like
no not i'm truly not even a little bit i
mean yeah would it be annoying if i
tweet something out and they suspend you
and then you can't you know it's
annoying and it is a symptom of a
disease don't get me wrong this desire
to suppress
by you know the mob this desire to say
oh you think differently like look what
was labeled misinformation most of what
was labeled misinformation the last two
years wound up being accurate
information let's be honest and now you
can't you know call a man a man a woman
what biology ceases to matter words
cease to matter the word female has been
cha now it's gotta you know everybody's
gotta be made to feel good about
themselves so we gotta change that word
in the dictionary you know it's all
about a p it's all emotional they want
to hold the left now seems to want a
whole world that's just subjective
nothing's grounded in reality and
nothing's grounded in facts and there's
a reason for that because in the land of
reality in fact they lose they never
come to the table with facts they never
come to the table with policies that
actually work they come to the table
with feelings they come to the table
that's not fair that's not just you know
redistribute the wealth and all of this
like oh you know we need to create a
fair society and in the process they
create a society a society where people
are out of work where people can't
afford to fill their gas tanks where
people are struggling where people view
each other as the enemy where community
and family disappear i mean all of these
things where crime is on the rise
where
they they break stuff in the process of
trying to create what's fair it's all
language game but i'm not interested in
the world in the land of oz you know i'm
not looking to go over the rainbow and
sit in the little pot of gold that
doesn't exist
so
i'm comfortable in the space sound man
i'm very as you may have noticed yeah
how do you really feel i can't i'm not
reading you here what's going on here
really should be more blonde with you
dave i really should
so i want to back up to something that
you said a minute or two ago about some
of the things that you talk about
besides politics you mentioned
men and you mentioned relationships
you know i toured with jordan peterson
for a year and a half and he was always
a large portion of his audience was was
males who were trying to you know stand
up straight with their shoulders back
get their lives in order and it does
seem like we have this like dearth in
society of men
that have their [ __ ] together basically
that are kind of living the right way to
find a woman or find a dude or whatever
uh but to live like a full
life it seems worse somehow it seems
worse for men than women right now do
you think that's fair to say and what do
you think that what do you think's going
on there well i think there's been a
demonization of men you know and i think
feminism you know and when i say
feminism i don't mean feminism as it was
intended you know a lot of the founding
feminists were pro-life i mean it was a
very different vision they had they were
talking about you know equality of
opportunity they were talking about a
society where women had the chance to
succeed removing those very legitimate
barriers that existed for women at the
time
um and it was it was a very pro-life
movement as i said i'm talking about the
feminism of today how it's been morphed
how it's been taken over by the left and
now it's like it's empowering somehow
for women to be [ __ ] it's empowering
for women to you know to rag on men you
saw what happened to kavanaugh at that
disgraceful i mean they just tore that
man down with no evidence they were just
they've decide they made a decision
about who he was this idea that men you
know are bad or oh men should take a
backseat and be quiet and let the women
talk this idea of toxic masculinity and
oftentimes what's referred to as toxic
masculinity is just men being gentlemen
men wanting to take care of themselves
and take care of their families yes men
being strong so i take all of these
things on and i think that men in many
ways have it harder and this is near and
dear to my heart because i'm raising a
son you know i'm raising a son at a time
where men are too easily demonized where
boys on college campuses are being told
to sit down and shut up it happens all
the time where they're told oh take a
bat seat let the women talk or their you
know sexual harassment charges just
because you're charged with something
now means you're guilty if you're a guy
so this is all near and dear to my heart
i think feminism has in many ways
damaged men and damaged women you know i
i played a clip the other day on my show
of a woman out there talking about you
know how it was empowering for her to be
[ __ ] and you know was the patriarchy's
fault that everything that happened to
her was the default effect of the
patriarchy and you know all this
nonsense and i'm like you know they
they've really done a disservice to
women women who now you know women who
now think it's it's shameful to be a
housewife
why
it's shameful to be or or being a mom
isn't being a mom is the most important
job i have it's the most wonderful
rewarding important job that i have that
was my super power right carrying a baby
that was my super they've robbed women
of all these and now they're robbing
them of more right they're taking their
trophies they're taking all of their oh
woman of the year it doesn't go to
biological women anymore we've got to
make everybody feel welcome so i think
feminism has done a huge disservice in
short to men and to women and what
should really exist is mutual respect
people who respect themselves
who care about you know themselves who
are free thinking individuals and who
respect each other and that's been lost
and i think walked all over by feminism
of modern day feminists should say
there there's obviously so many weird
parts of this i mean the idea that the
people who were championing women are
literally championing a guy with a penis
i mean leah thomas has a penis that's
just a fact uh connor my director over
here mentioned the other day why is he
or she such a good swimmer because maybe
it acts as a propeller i thought that
that was pretty i thought that that was
pretty clever um
but amazing but but the people the i
it's it's good it's good but the people
who
were championing women are now
championing this guy girl whatever you
want to say uh as the winner and i think
it is my belief that i think women want
regular dudes i i think they want those
guys that open the door and do those
gentlemanly things and actually take
care of themselves the other meme on
this one is that every other week one of
daily beasts or salon or one of these
idiotic websites write how working out
is now part of the alt-right you know
the far right is using fitness as a tool
to recruit
it's like all of these things would that
would make you feel empowered as a
person right all of these things health
and wellness being fit feeling strong
you know wanting a strong man beside you
wanting a gentleman you know being
comfortable in your own skin these are
all things you know why because they
want a society of dependence right they
want you weak they want you subservient
they want you feeling unhappy with
yourself so now you have to what maybe
go live in the metaverse and maybe a big
tech guy can go make a bunch of money
off of it because you're too afraid to
enter the real world
don't forget the prescription pills
don't forget the prescription pills
exactly right i was just going to get to
that they want you chronically ill
because then you're a repeat customer
for big pharma and this idea of being
healthy and fortified and that's very
threatening to a lot of the ideologies
the spouse by the left and a lot of
people they love and they you know
change dollars with oftentimes whatever
so
in terms of big pharma i mean yeah so
yeah
this sense of personal responsibility
this is their enemy this is their number
one enemy and i do think that women want
gentlemen i do i think that they i think
that those women that buy into this
nonsense all the time and hear all this
nonsense about how oh when a guy opens a
door for you they're just trying to make
you feel small no honey they're trying
to be a jump he knows he knows that when
he opened the door for you that you
could if you wanted to you've got arms
you can open it yourself he's trying to
be respectful most women absolutely do
want that and most women want a man who
can defend himself most women want a man
who who cares about taking care of
himself and his family
you know they they want a man they don't
want a boy they don't want a boy who
needs a safe space they want a man and
they've been trained that that's a bad
thing somehow and some of them take the
bait and you know what winds up to those
people those women wind up very unhappy
they want to very unhappy very very
unhappy in life because they're
listening to this nonsense and a wind up
alone oftentimes because they've bought
the story they've bought the story so i
think it's a lot of it is about
it's not you know rejecting modern day
feminism is about embracing female
endowment it's not about tearing it down
it's about saying you it's it's you you
dress [ __ ] you attract the wrong kind
of guy that's on you that's on you own
your own decisions your own choices and
what is the result of those choices own
it all and you'll feel some control over
your own life for a change
jedi i uh as you know i am off the grid
at the moment
well you know we're this is a delayed
taping so i'm somewhere right now
possibly a father it's unknown at the
moment but i'm off the grid uh do you
ever do any kind of off the grid
disconnect any version of any of that i
think i've seen you maybe tweet about
some weekends off for that kind of thing
because you know when you're in this
machine it just kind of never stops and
you've been able to stay sane throughout
this yeah i mean i don't know if i'd say
sane but i'm trying my best but yeah i
always say roughly saying if you're
roughly saying these days you're good in
my book and i have a pretty wide lane on
that yeah exactly yeah the news cycle
can be can be very challenging um it's a
crazy world i i don't know if you know
about anything about the books that i
wrote before dear hartley but i wrote a
book called do not disturb
and it was about that it was about the
need to kind of remove yourself from
technology take those breaks it was a
lot about actually it predated a lot of
what we know about social media now and
a lot of the conversation and talked
about like how we're being programmed to
be a bunch of addicted robots and how
much joy and peace and sanity we get
back when we just take that time away so
i will take i don't know in the past
couple of years i don't know if i've
taken a block of time but i'll even take
a couple of days where i'll just shut
the phone off i'll let everybody know
like hey
i'm i'm spending time with my family i'm
recharging i'm going to watch a good
movie i'm going to walk on the beach i'm
going to absorb a sunset i don't want to
know what's going on like believe me
it's not going to break that badly you
can wait another day and it's very very
important i find i find people that even
you know aren't in media life is hard
right now for a lot of people people are
struggling they've lost their jobs in
many cases they're going to you know go
into the grocery store and inflation has
prices sky-high of common goods and
services you know gas prices it's it's
scary for a lot of people and i've been
in that position you know dave i don't
know how much you know about me but i
was a waitress i grew up in a very
middle class family that struggled
financially
i didn't have money so i understand what
financial struggle means
i was a teacher like kind of like
struggling to pay bills for a long time
so i know that feeling and i think it's
so important to kind of in those moments
i think get away from your phone step
away recharge with your family remember
what's good about your life remember
what feels good nature is always very
restorative it's essential or you'll
you'll really lose your mind you'll wind
up then stressed then next thing you
know you've got anxiety then you got you
know big pharma rolling in with their
you know medication so
thank you my friend i look forward to
seeing you
in florida
in the fall thanks so much dave
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about the media
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our media playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics check out the full episode
playlist they're both right over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell